you're welcome to this video I'm playing
the modern feds against cal mil G from
Poland I guess this opponent yeah he
responded with g3 self many possible
transpositions maybe I can play some
some h5 trying to irritate him a bit now
try to stay within them modern defense
area here with e 5 96 ah before yeah
that's a remarkable muth very early I
take here what is he playing p 5 ok
they are very quickly don't know okay
this is a distant Rudy reteaming now
I've got a nice square on 95 IDK don't
really play a for this is far too
weakening this is also nice square okay
yeah it just gives away bishop and now
it was saying yeah this is quite weird
or just bad I mean giving up an
important bishop and allowing this year
yeah maybe needs to do something like
look T 1
it's Bishop f5 a good move and yeah
that's more than one good move okay but
this is certainly not bad okay Quinn
takes you wait wait let's let's let's
calculate just just for a moment I'm
attacking the Queen and I'm also
attacking the night we should take some
might have some point 23 this is a good
a good option Queen d3 attacking the
night and if it moves the c3 falling
yeah I can just take a play wiki tool
mmm not sure how good this is no not bad
okay too well yeah it's probably right
he's a decking be 70 juicer quite
annoying
I wonder I wonder I wonder if I play
Bishop before am i threatening they were
threatening to play Queen g3 I think I
am but he's got look f.2d one hug f.2d
one
okay let's let's let's consolidate and
that's improve here and of course
everything instantly never think it must
be great
okay but on the other hand what what am
i doing now
now probably this one
yeah coogi 3 m's this is this business
possible this one was my idea I really
hope it works
he takes rook g2 checking h moy and
resins wow he's quick and playing and
quicken resigning is really winning I
thought I think so but my idea was take
and then this one I don't see how it
prevents the major there is no way rook
h2 andrew g to mate cannot prevent it
something like this yeah yeah it's also
made yeah once in a while I mean people
keep complaining that I criticize the
time management of the other place I
mean but sometimes it's really helpful
if you think a bit for some reason I
cannot take the moves back when one can
I do that strange
so I cannot make up moves this is weird
yeah well anyway the thing is here he
needs to play something else I'm not
sure maybe a rook rook rook somewhere
and the comp actually gives me a winning
position already I mean I was optimistic
but I'm surprised they're definitely not
working was this because of Queen g3 and
it's really a major Quinn g3 as a maid
first made in eight moves actually I
didn't see that I only saw it its
winning but and curious however the
yellow I played every move instantly but
it's very hard to say here oh here here
this is stronger you look 833 wins this
is this is very strong look 823 I
somehow cannot put it on the board why
is that wait maybe I need to do this
there's also not working don't ask me
some I cannot examine this year Brooke
a2 a3 is very strong as I cannot do that
as well Brooke 823 him i played this
which seems to be good as well but not
so good look do you want us to move that
Brooke 81 the computer gives us though
we are continuing the game not being a
maid but Bishop g2 Quincy throughly as a
maid yeah the fun ending here thanks for
watching